catastrophe continues to mount over at
the southern border according to the
associated press haitian migrants
seeking to escape poverty hunger and a
feeling of hopelessness in their home
country said they will not be deterred
by u.s plans to speedily send them back
as thousands of people remain encamped
on the texas border saturday after
crossing from mexico scores of people
waded back and forth across the rio
grande on saturday afternoon re-entering
mexico to purchase water food and
diapers in ciudad acuna before returning
to the texas encampment under a near a
bridge in the border city of del rio now
remember we were told a wall was
completely unnecessary because if there
is a river there no one would actually
cross that river well um it seems like
people are crossing the river and then
going back and forth across the river
many times and finding as it turns out
holes in america's border system where
they can descend on areas and then apply
for asylum junior jean a 32 year old man
from haiti watched as people
cautiously carried cases of water or
bags of food through the knee-high river
water
jean said he lived on the streets in
chile the past four years resigned to
searching for food in garbage cans
okay so what drove him now if he was in
chile for the past four years what
exactly was the big driver right now
could it have something to do with the
advent of a brand new administration
that is not led by donald trump he said
we're all looking for a better life the
department of homeland security said
saturday had moved about 2 000 of the
migrants from the camp to other
locations on friday for processing and
possible removal from the united states
they also said they'd have 400 agents
and officers in the area by monday
morning now here's the reason why they
are doing that the reason that they are
sending a bunch of new officers is of
course because it had been humiliating
to them that the state of texas had
actually intervened and sent its own
officers right that's actually what
happened here is that the state of texas
sent law enforcement officers according
to daily wire law enforcement officials
with the state of texas appear to have
taken control of the situation in del
rio texas after the biden administration
repeatedly failed to stop tens of
thousands of migrants from illegally
entering the united states governor greg
abbott said in a tweet quote the texas
department of public safety is in full
force along the border around the del
rio area and then he put out a picture
that showed scores of law enforcement
vehicles that had descended on the area
he said they built a barricade with
their squad cars and state troopers the
national guard is working with them to
secure the border as well
fox news national correspondent bill
malugan tweeted out a video showing the
massive surge in law enforcement
presence at the border the texas
department of public safety tweeted out
photographs from both the ground and
from their drone showing the scale of
the abbott response to the crisis that
started late last week and erupted over
the past few days and of course the
texas department of public safety noted
their response came after the federal
government had failed to secure the
board when we say they had failed to
secure the border we actually have some
pictures and video of what it looks like
when you fail to secure the border here
is a picture from the air of the migrant
camp which is under a freeway overpass
and if you can't see it i will describe
it for you it is literally thousands
upon thousands of people who are
standing under an overpass many of them
in 100 degree heat
a lot of them as it turns out from some
of the from some of the video have built
themselves sort of ram shackle
structures using essentially leaves and
sticks in order that they don't burn to
death or dehydrate to death under the
overpass so it's a humanitarian crisis
as well fox news is bill mclugan he says
listen our border is wide open
this is where hundreds of people are
streaming into the united states
illegally right now uh certainly does
not look like an international border
there but you can see the crowds of
people down there these are people who
have just crossed it and brian if we can
pan up that dirt path take a look that's
where they're all walking to the bridge
right now that's why there's so many
people under the bridge you can see them
streaming in across the rio grande that
they that's when they officially cross
illegally into the united states and
seeing the scope of it all over the
place
it's wild i mean our border is wide open
where you're looking at right now yeah
amazingly the faa had actually attempted
to ban drone footage from this
particular area citing lack of safety
protocols which of course is incredibly
silly because they've had drones over
there for quite a while that was purely
an attempt to stop the news from
covering it and then when they got
caught then they reversed themselves
some of the video from under the bridge
is just as disturbing as some of the
you know 500 000 foot video that you're
seeing right there here's some of the
video from from underneath the bridge
that was taken also by bill malugan
if you can't see it again you're seeing
huge crowds of people these are the
structures i was talking about blankets
small children some of the people who
are who are sitting here in the in the
sunshine
it's unbelievable it's a refugee camp
directly on the board now i have a
question where is aoc she still at the
met gala
i was told that that i i know that that
parking lots adjacent to holding
facilities really upset her upset her so
much that she shows up there wearing
white costumes and uh and then stands
outside and cries directly into camera i
know it's very upsetting to see large
stretches of pavement and no actual
migrants there but you know when there's
like thousands of migrants under an
overpass many of them suffering from
humanitarian need i don't see her
anywhere but i guess she was at the met
gala so she was she was you know she was
busy and meanwhile the democratic mayor
of del rio is slamming joe biden
he is his name is bruno ralph lazana he
tweeted out the u.s is failing to
protect its borders why aren't you here
he was tweeting out at vice president
kamala harris
okay
meanwhile you had the representative
august flager republican of texas saying
yeah this is a pretty major crisis that
we are looking at right now this is not
just some sort of temporary problem and
of course this is part of a broader
crisis okay here's representative flager
you can see the tragedy coming across
the weir dam we're about 100 yards away
from the international bridge in del rio
over 14 800 people as of this morning up
from 12 000 up from 10 000 and this week
we have surged from 1 to 2 000 to 14
000. this is a crisis we need the
administration to call it a crisis to
take action not just here but all along
our southern border where we're going to
have two million people
illegal immigrants that are documented
that doesn't include the guidance that
doesn't include the known or suspected
terrorists we need the administration to
do something right now according to
fluger a lot of these people are
military aged males he reportedly told
fox news there was allegedly criminal
activity taking place in the area where
illegal immigrants were staying under
the bridge
according to fluger the border officials
told him this was the worst they have
ever seen it he also said this was worse
than you could imagine and he said the
worst is yet to come because if they
decide to riot or if unrest happened it
would be a terrible situation it's ripe
it's 100 degrees outside right now you
literally have 14 878 people here that's
how serious the situation is right now
even the new york times reported that
local officials are describing the scene
as a quote shanty town with little
access to clean water and food and just
a few portable toilets the times noted
no running water at the site photos
showed people having to carry large
packages of bottled water into the area
so as i say the governor of texas sent
some people in there to try and clean
things up and this then prompted the
biden administration to respond the u.s
is now saying that we are going to start
flying people out of there apparently
we're going to start flying five to
eight flights a day from the area
starting on sunday another official from
the government expected no more than two
a day said everyone would be tested for
covet 19. now remember that had been one
of the republican complaints that people
who are being released into the interior
of the united states are not actually
being tested for coven 19 before they
are being released
told of the us's plans on saturday
several migrants said they still
intended to remain in the encampment and
seeking asylum
some spoke of the most recent
devastating earthquake in haiti as well
as the assassination of president
jovenal moisey saying they were afraid
to return to a country that seemed more
unstable than when they left in the
first place
it was a full-scale disaster area again
the reason this is happening is not just
because of foreign crisis
the reality is foreign crisis exists all
over the world
for
oodles of time
the northern triangle countries have had
serious internal problems for decades at
this point there is nothing new under
the sun what changed here is that joe
biden became president and people have
decided that they are now going to try
to brave the journey hoping that joe
biden is going to let them in this is
finally prompting dhs to use some
trumpian type language the department of
homeland security said quote our borders
are not open people should not make the
dangerous journey individuals and
families are subject to border
restrictions including expulsions of the
agency irregular migration poses a
significant threat to the health and
welfare of border communities and to the
lives of migrants themselves and should
not be attempted but of course there
have been a lot of public interviews
with people who are attempting to make
that crossing and it turns out that many
of them are saying we don't believe you
we think that you are faking and we
think that in reality if we cross the
border and if we are released into the
interior you will plan immediately to
give us some sort of amnesty which of
course is true
which is why you've seen a massive surge
since joe biden was elected in the first
place according to the washington post
this is as of last month the number of
migrants detained along the mexico
border crossed a new threshold in july
exceeding 200 000 people for the first
time in 21 years according to cbp
among the 213 000 migrants taken into us
custody in july of this year were 83 000
family members and 19 000 unaccompanied
teenagers and children that was an
all-time high as well again aoc nowhere
to be found she was wearing attacks the
rich stress created as it turns out by a
possible tax cheat so you know she's
busy she's busy
as of july more than 15 000 miners who
arrived without parents were in
government custody many sleeping in grim
military barracks a south texas park
along the rio grande had been converted
into a sprawling quarantine camp for
more than a thousand parents and
children who had tested positive for
covet or been exposed to infection
all of this by the way has prompted the
biden administration
to actually embrace many of the exact
same policies that the trump
administration embraced so now they've
surged a bunch of people to the border
according to the wall street journal the
biden administration sent more agents to
the texas bridge to move haitian
migrants this was as of sunday the biden
administration said it would be sending
additional border agents u.s customs and
border protection plans to send 400
agents and officers to del rio and was
moving migrants to other processing
locations along the border including
about 2000 on friday now remember that
still leaves somewhere between 12 and 13
000 people who are not moved from that
area as of sunday
dhs also said they were going to start
flying people back to haiti on sunday as
well
haitians apparently have been coming at
a steady clip all year long to del rio a
remote border region of the border west
of san antonio creating a fresh
humanitarian crisis in a year when
illegal boarding when illegal border
crossings have hit a two-decade high
and the biden administration has been
struggling to handle a crush of asylum
seekers the border patrol has facilities
that are not large enough to accommodate
the recent crush they've instead been
holding migrants under the bridge often
for days because they literally have no
place else to put these people and they
are processing their immigration
paperwork
so full on disaster on thursday by the
way a federal judge in washington ruled
the biden administration was violating
immigration law by rapidly expelling
migrant families using the title 42
policy that judge stated the effect of
his decision for two weeks
on friday the administration appealed
the decision to a higher court so the
obama administration came into office
pledging they were going to reverse all
of trump's evil horrible no good very
bad immigration policies and they've
been avidly attempting to
reinforce those exact same policies
while claiming that they have radically
changed things
right so you get the worst of both
worlds you get the abiding
administration which is apparently
engaging in precisely the sort of evil
humanitarian anti-humanitarian measures
as trump and the message is come on in
which is rather conflict which is rather
conflicting
box.com reported on this just a little
while ago
they reported quote despite promises to
institute a more humane immigration
policy the biden administration has
clung to related border restrictions
like title 42 implemented by the trump
administration last year since march
2020 that policy had had been used to
rapidly expel more than a million
migrants without hearings before an
immigration judge
biden also pledged to remember that he
was going to get rid of trump's
remaining mexico policy this is people
who were applying for asylum and the
idea was that instead of us releasing
you to the interior while you await your
court hearing instead if you want to
apply for asylum you gotta wait in
mexico while we go through your
paperwork okay trump had negotiated that
deal with the mexican government and now
biden came in he said i'm getting rid of
it
but he reversed himself because it turns
out that when you reverse all of the
sensical logical policies bad things
happen
all the while biden's message has been
quote unquote don't come
toward haitians specifically biden's
policies are wildly inconsistent again
this isn't me this is vox.com which is a
biden shearing section quote he has
allowed more than a hundred thousand
haitians already living in the u.s to
apply for temporary protected status at
the same time has continued to prevent
haitians waiting on the other side of
the us-mexico border from entering under
title 42 and to the shock of immigration
advocates resumed deportation flights to
haiti on wednesday
so
again conflicting policy
bad policy
bad rhetoric
and the predictable result is a mess on
the border remember kamala harris was
supposed to solve this didn't they put
her in charge of the border crisis
that was funny i mean not like not like
funny enough for kamala harris to laugh
the way she does that's just weird but
but funny that they put her in charge of
the border crisis and it's been a
complete and utter failure
this is just part and parcel again of
the internally conflicting messaging of
this administration and the wild
incompetence of this administration as
well
it's amazing that the rip on trump is
that his team was wildly incompetent
i'll tell you a few things that trump
didn't do
he didn't lead to a 21-year high in
illegal immigration
and have no actual plan to deal with it
he also i noticed didn't abandon
afghanistan to the tender predations of
the taliban and leave thousands of green
card holders behind notice that one as
well
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe
you